i'm leaving don't try to find me don't
be absurd aj where would you go you have
blood on your hands mother i won't be a
part of this family you will always be
ashamed
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
right
[Music]
you're my guardian angel
where's dark save your life i just wiped
the mud off
that thing was made by the chase
don't you believe in second chances not
for them
what's wrong nothing just
join the frontier corps to help people
not to shine doing that
if it weren't for you
i'd be dead already
but there are some things you can't
change
unless you've got a fresh stash of meds
lying around
i'll figure something out
i'll find a way
[Music]
listen silva
i need your help
who's that guy oh
come on come on what are you doing and
what's your wear and you look ridiculous
say hi chica what do you mean you said
your dog was donating the meds yes he
just doesn't know it yet
check out this suit awesome right why
would you need a wing suit why would you
not need a ring suit
you're serious i'm always serious
you just can't tell because of the mask
we're not doing this
hey
if you really want to help your
boyfriend
this is the only way
fine
what is your plan
well
i made us this playlist
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to my channel
[Music]
uh
[Music]
hands up
don't move
wow chica nice moves
that was easy eh
you won't believe what i'm looking at
right now
ah chica
we should go am i any different from my
parents
probably
you have 10 seconds to surrender
10
9
21
now this is my speech
what
[Music]
you always
should have been faster
[Music]
[Music]
ow
get these to the others
i've got you
you made it
in here
nobody moved please
where is my daughter
[Music]
i won't ask so politely next time
[Music]
wait
there you are my darling quite a mess
you've made
i'm so sorry stop
you don't want them you want me
promise to leave these people alone and
i'll come home
very well
this time you'll do as you're told
yes mother
go ahead captain
consider this a lesson in the family
business
we do whatever it takes
welcome to our channel we're here in the
midst of a wild hosting situation smash
that like button whatever happens next
the whole outlands will know about it
you're such a disappointment boy
let's go
thanks for the donation pops
[Applause]
you'll always be ashamed nothing can
change that
[Music]
he was right you know you'll always be
ashamed
but when has that ever stopped you
take silva
what are we gonna do next time you run
out
whatever it takes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]